as soon as we continue on our journey
with DC rebirth stuff what I want to do
here is I want a back pedal for a little
bit and the reason why is because all of
you 100 songs for the guys I have not
been the most diligent DC fan there ever
was you know I was largely a Marvel fan
I was raised on Marvel read Marvel for
decades when I sat down and started
reading DC rebirth I was like this is
amazing and I think that in you know
becoming overzealous by reading
Detective Comics Batman
especially Superman in action comics you
know the flash I was really caught up
and you know and the lightning strikes
twice the whole god speed story arc the
son of Superman element you know the
supose adore the presumed death of Tim
Drake which we know is not the case you
know I got caught up in all that and it
didn't even occur to me I should go back
and probably do the number ones that lay
the groundwork for all this stuff so
over the course of the next few months
I'm gonna be peppering in the DC rebirth
one-shot so bear with me you know on
those things because I don't you know
even if only for the sake of having them
in the playlists and giving you guys a
place to start as you're getting into DC
rebirth you know I want them to be there
I want to have those these videos done
having said that the flash rebirth
number one is probably the most
important out of all the rebirth 1 shots
and the reason is this when DC launched
the new 52 in 2011 what they said was
that prior to the new 52 Barry Allen had
the genius idea of going back in time
and saving his mom's life saving her
from being killed by eobard thawne he
did that and it resulted in the
flashpoint universe where everything was
all screwed up Wonder Woman in Aquaman
were at war with one another Bruce Wayne
died instead of his parents and so
Thomas William became Batman Martha
Wayne went insane and became a joker it
created all these crazy scenarios and it
was really really fun the issue with
this was that the story had to end
somehow and so the story concluded with
Barry Allen realizing what it was that
he had done after he'd been taunted by
professor zoom Barry Allen went back in
time again to stop himself from saving
his mother's life and when the dust
settled then it was all said and done we
got the new 52 and what DC said was that
when the new 52 first started that it
had been five years since the appearance
of superheroes so basically we picked up
five years after the new 52 universe was
essentially born we had Batman and we
got all you know the origin stories
Superman so on and so forth the issue
was that the new 52 was not wild
well-received people kind of liked it
but they didn't like it it brought in a
host of new fans but as the years passed
and as the number ones turned into
number tens turned into number 20s after
a while people started losing interest
this was especially prevalent with
events like convergence and DCU and so
what happened is Africa you know at the
direction of geoff johns Godfrey's his
name he came and he launched the DC
rebirth event and what he said was what
we were told of the new 52 that's not
true that doesn't apply what he said
with a DC Universe number one story is
that some time and maybe it was a
fraction of a second maybe it was days
years whatever but at some point after
Barry Allen had kept himself from saving
his mom's life instead of the new 52
just coming into existence that dr.
Manhattan of the Watchmen universe a guy
that can do anything he's literally God
he can control molecules and atoms he
can manipulate time he can reconstitute
himself I mean he's quite he's the
quintessential God in comics that
somewhere along the line he had shown up
in the new 52 universe and he had stolen
ten years out of everybody's life and so
when we got the new 52 flash in the new
52 Batman with the new 52 Superman and
so on and so forth they were operating
without realizing dr. Manhattan had
screwed up that dr. Mann hadn't had
taken ten years away from them so hope
you guys are following me on that is
that's basically where we stand right
now with DC rebirth it's kind of going
in and retconning the new 52 you but the
fact remains that with the flash rebirth
we we sort of learned what was happening
with a DC Universe rebirth number one
that that one shot that we got that kind
of set everything in motion it was
literally just the free new 52 wally
west running around and trying to get
people to realize who he is but no one
recognized it no one knew who he was
because again they had no memory of
anything before the new 52 and so
because of this the flash number one
essentially picks up with Barry Allen
this is why I say this is the most
important one because this is when we
start learning everything of course this
initially picks up with a crime scene
that's almost identical to the crime
scene of Barry Allen's mother in the
sense that a person named Heather Macy
had been killed the father had been
suspected of it or he was the one that
was believed to be the one who committed
this crime and the son claimed it was a
monster again this is almost identical
to Barry Allen's history just because of
the fact that when Barry Allen was a
child you know his mother was killed the
father was believed to have been the one
that killed her
but we know that it was actually eobard
thawne who had traveled from the future
and Barry Allen had said it was a
monster that had killed my mother and so
again it's almost identical here and
this is actually recognized by you know
the crime scene investigators director a
guy named Singh now he's been around for
a long time as part of the Barry Allen
mythos but basically he says because
these cases are so similar Barry Allen
should not have a role in this
investigation just because of the fact
that it would be too personal you know
he would you would more or less be an
instance where Barry Allen was trying to
solve as Vizier I guess trying to relive
solving his mom's own murder by trying
to solve this one so again it wouldn't
just be a crime you know he would it
would hit hit too close to home but in
the midst of this Barry Allen suddenly
starts getting these experiences these
headaches now of course we know that one
of these guys is god speed we ran over
that story lightning strikes twice we
know what he is we know how that turns
out we know what direction things go in
but he also gets a vision of Wally West
now Barry does not know this is the pre
new 52 Wally West to him it's just some
guy saying his name and maybe it's
visions maybe it's alternate realities
other dimensions Barry doesn't really
know what to make of this not only that
he also sees a vision of eobard thawne
now eobard thawne did exist in the new
52 and his story was changed a little
bit and this is really the question here
are we going to see the you know the
original flash rebirth storyline under
Geoff Johns are we going to see that
that history of Barry Allen or are we
going to stick with the new 52 history
of Barry Allen at this moment we don't
really know but we do know that eobard
thawne is a villain that is recognized
by Barry Allen and he hallucinates him
in place of Singh and so as a result
Singh says hey man like do you need to
you need a minute like you need to calm
down what's going on and Barry Allen
says now I just I just need a moment to
get things figured out and this is when
Joshua Williamson kind of tells us
what's going on from Barry Allen's
perspective and he essentially tells us
that Barry Allen was you know struck by
lightning and also doused in a series of
chemicals it resulted in him gaining
SuperSpeed and he decided to take on the
mantle of this of the flash now this is
the reason why I say the whole Geoff
Johns rebirth thing is a question that I
have is because when Geoff Johns brought
Barry Allen back to the DC landscape 20
years after his death
during crisis on Infinite Earths he
reckoned so much history of his
character during the the crisis on
Infinite Earths era and before crisis on
Infinite Earths
the story of Barry Allen is
exactly what we're seeing here that he
was just a guy who was working in an
office he was you know covered in
chemicals he was struck by lightning
just basically in the wrong place at the
wrong time and it resulted in him being
the flash so I guess maybe it's the
right place at the right time but that
was the story of Barry Allen it was
simple no muss no fuss easy to figure
out over the years the villain eobard
thawne had been introduced as a guy who
was obsessed with Barry Allen in the
future and there was all kinds of
confusing scenarios but it was largely
part of Mark Wade's run on eobard thawne
you know when he was writing Wally West
flash but he was also part of the
pre-crisis the pre-crisis on Infinite
Earths legacy of a very Alan and so what
Geoff Johns did with the original flash
rebirth event is he took all that
history of eobard thawne and he
condensed it down and made it super
simple and what he said was that in the
future eobard thawne had become obsessed
with the idea of Barry Allen and he
really wanted to meet his idol so what
he did is he travelled back to the past
realized that he was going to become the
villain eobard thawne went insane and
the result was that he literally started
engineering the events of Barry Allen's
life that led him to becoming the flash
and so instead of it simply being that
Barry Allen was just the flash one day
eobard thawne's set all those things in
motion
eobard thawne was the reason wise family
moved to Central City the apart Thawne
was the reason why the chemicals were
placed in the order that they were
placed in so that when Barry Allen was
struck by lightning and doused in the
chemicals he would become the flash and
eobard thawne was the one that killed
Barry Allen's mother giving him a reason
to become the flash in the first place
he had literally manipulated every
moment of his life to the point where he
became the flash that was all Geoff
Johns flash rebirth the original story
what Joshua Williams seems to be doing
here even if only for the sake of
keeping things simple is not including
that information instead he's going with
the original crisis you know pre crisis
on Infinite Earths very allen origin
story where he was just covered in
chemicals struck by lightning became the
flash done and done so what we end up
doing here is because Barry Allen is is
more or less trying to figure out
everything that's going on much like in
the TV show his father is the one guy
that he divulges everything to and talks
to about what it is that's bothering him
then as he's talking to Henry Allen he's
running over these different things that
seem to be taking place about what Henry
Allen also says is if you believe this
is a Speed Force sending you messages
and the question is does anybody ever
bother to research the
forced to learn everything they can
about the speedforce what is capable up
now again all this is based on the new
52 Barry Allen so he doesn't remember
anything before the new 52 he doesn't
remember being trapped in the Speed
Force for 20 years when he supposedly
died after crisis on Infinite Earths he
doesn't remember emerging from the Speed
Force during in or during final crisis
he doesn't remember any of the of the
retcon you know with with eobard thawne
to him it's just the Speed Force is just
some energy out there that he accesses
whenever he's a speedster whenever he's
running around and that's all there is
to it and so what is what his dad does
is he offers a few comforting words as
hey look sometimes or maybe some things
here that are you know beyond your
control or beyond your ability to
understand but your scientist you'll get
it figured out eventually and so Barry
Allen doesn't really take a whole lot of
comfort in these words but what he also
does is he says hey look you know as the
flash I am an investigator I am a
scientist my goal is to get these sort
of things figured out and it's really
just him kind of killing time you know
until his investigations in this
particular crime can be taken care of by
the equipment in the lab but in the
middle of this he suddenly met with the
arrival of Wally West from the pre new
52 and this is why I say this is when
everything turns gets turned on its head
this is when everything just suddenly
you know flips over and this is Joshua
Williamson telling us hey look there's a
lot going on out here now because Wally
West and the DC Universe rebirth number
one had traveled around a Batman and all
these different heroes none of whom
remember who he was he had kind of
resigned himself to the fact that he's
part of a timeline that doesn't exist
anymore a timeline that's basically
fading away to the point where it will
be completely non-existent and it'll
it'll disappear in its entirety but
Barry Allen is his last link to that and
all it takes is for Barry Allen to
remember him and say his name in order
for Wally West and that universe to come
into existence and that's exactly what
happens because Barry Allen says or
recognizes him as Wally West the pre new
52 Wally West is now here he is now in
our reality and this is basically Joshua
Williamson saying that I guess at this
very moment right now until we get an
answer to the question of what dr.
Manhattan was doing that the pre new 52
landscape is still there we're in the
new 52 universe right now but elements
of the pre new 52 universe are still
there so the best way to think about
this is that if you have you know two
rooms
and a door separates those rooms that
door is you know flashpoint and whatever
it is a doctor Manhattan did you know on
the left side of the door is the pre new
52 universe and on the right side of the
door is the new 52 universe basically
what happened is wally west stuck his
hand through that door or barry allen
grabbed it pulled him in and so now that
universe is there you know we're just
trying to figure out what it is it
happened that led to all these
superheroes forgetting everything
and that's exactly what wally west says
here wally west says something happened
i don't know what that something is
but something happened and none of you
remember the way things used to be none
of you remember how things used to be
and so what may happen here is DC may
come along and say this isn't new 52 you
know this is all free new 52 it's just
your memories have been changed or
you've forgotten things or something
else has happened we don't really know
what direction DC is gonna go with this
but what DC is establishing with this
particular this particular comic is
they're saying all the stuff that you
remember is still there now though pick
and choose you know if there are
elements of the pre new 52 landscape
they were just really bad those won't
get included you know but all the stuff
that we love is basically DC saying hey
all that stuff is still here right now
you know all that stuff is still present
now initially because of the fact that
all this is coming back to Barry Allen
because Wally West says hey there was an
event called flashpoint and you're the
one that created this universe that
you're in right now you know you're the
one that created all this because he's
being informed of all this stuff his
initial idea is okay well just go let's
just start telling people let's go tell
people what's going on I mean I'm Barry
Allen they know me they don't know you
but they know me and they trust me
they'll believe me when I say hey look
this guy is from a universe that we
thought was dead but he says he knows
everything that's been going on or knows
how we used to be while we can't
remember things so on and so forth but
Wally West says no like people just
aren't ready for it yet you know they're
they're not even ready for it yet
because they don't know everything
that's going on you all they know is
suddenly you know someone took years off
of their life out of their memories and
and no one knows who did it or why that
person didn't or you know where that
person came from or anything and so
while Barry initially says hey let's go
talk to Irish he's a really good friend
of mine for Wally West in the pre
flashpoint Wally West in his mind Barry
Allen and iris West are married and so
for him it's weird that there are only
friends in this particular timeline and
so the idea is okay no we need to hold
off we don't need to tell people what's
going on once we get it
now then won't let people know what's
going on because it'll be able to go to
them and say hey guys here's everything
that's happening as opposed to showing
up on the doorstep of Batman and
Superman and Wonder Woman and saying hey
guys here's this dude from another
reality and someone stole 10 years of
our lives but we don't really know we
have no answers to the questions that
you're undoubtedly going to ask
it's just something happens somewhere
and we have no idea who did it it would
look kind of asinine
to be quite frank and so what is up
happening here is they kind of strike an
agreement of sorts that Barry Allen will
do what he can he'll of course be the
superhero and so on and so forth but in
the background and especially as part of
the Titans Wally West is going to try to
find answers to these questions now what
we do here is we transition to Batman
and Barry Allen's idea here is that
Batman's really more of a scientist than
a detective in the sense that Batman
basically just exists to try to solve
problems using science as best he can
and then using it in conjunction with
detective work and so for Barry he
basically says hey look man you know
here is what this Wally West told me
here's what he's been saying you know
but he also discovers that Batman had
located a button that was within the
Batcave and initially it was thought
that maybe the Joker left it there at
some point but we as the reader know
that button belongs to the watchman
specifically it belonged to the comedian
when he was killed what Barry Allen says
is that on this button is a trace of
radiation that none of them recognized
now we know that radiation to belong to
dr. Manhattan of the Watchmen universe
of this omnipotent wildly powerful being
that can basically do anything he wants
to and so why this buttons here how it
got here
we don't really know but as this comic
starts to wrap up what Joshua Williamson
also tells us here is that everything is
doomed to repeat itself what looks like
eobard thawne showing up at a house is
basically you know Joshua Wayne isn't
saying that history just always repeats
itself it's always just one big circle
everything comes back around again and
so what seems to be happening here at
least if I can just kind of speculate
off the top of my head can I can make
this talk about what I can basically say
here is that everything goes full circle
you know these universes come into
existence they're destroyed they're
recreated they you know they exist
they're destroyed they're recreated so
on and so forth that this is not the
first time something like this has
happened and it's doomed to repeat
itself but again I'm just kind of
throwing this out there you know I'm
just kind of speaking randomly into the
wind but hopefully you guys understand
what's going on right now for those of
you guys who were curious
where we are with DC we birth about the
pre new 52 versus the new 52 you
hopefully this this video allowed some
light bulbs to start clicking on so that
you guys have an understanding of what's
taking place and we can kind of go
forward into the different number ones
focusing on those characters
respectively but if you guys are still a
little bit confused and if you guys have
questions feel free to post them down in
the comment section I'll try to answer
them if I can if I can't for those of
you guys who are really well versed in
DC feel free to answer those as well
because I'd like this to be a session
where you know those of you guys who are
really knowledgeable about DC Comics can
offer your own input on what's going on
here and in some cases more so than I
can because I know there are a lot of
you guys out there they know a lot more
about DC than I do but in any event if
you guys are new here to comments
explained - feel free to hit the
subscribe button become part of the Rob
port and if you guys enjoy this video
drop a like and yeah I will see you all
later peace
[Music]